the u.s secret service
welcome i'm elizabeth christian i am ceo
of elizabeth christian public relations
and a vice chair of the lbj foundation
on behalf of the lbj foundation and the
lbj library it's my pleasure to welcome
you here tonight for an evening with
tonight we are really lucky to have with
us carol leonig ms lenig has just
written a book about the secret service
and our good friend evan smith ceo and
founder of the texas tribune is going to
be interviewing her tonight about this
what we know is that lady bird and
lyndon johnson had
the highest possible esteem for the
secret service dwight eisenhower called
them soldiers without a uniform
and yet over the last couple of decades
the reputation of the secret service has
taken a beating i'm hoping that evan and
carol can really get down to what has
happened with the service and what can
be done to fix it
so now please join me in welcoming carol
leonig and evan smith
carol good to be with you
congratulations on the book
thank you i'm so glad to be here with
you evan thank you well it's my pleasure
look the book is great
it's not only a great read but i learned
a lot
honestly i'm embarrassed as a political
junkie in a history buff i feel like i
should have known more of this than i
did let me off the hook how much of this
did you know before researching this
book
i have to say you know i really got into
this beat by accident looking at
something in 2012 a terrible scandal i
was really shocked
almost every time i delved into another
presidency and there was something new
to learn sometimes it was heroism
sometimes it was a you know security
debacle yeah
now as you say this was an outgrowth of
your reporting for the post on a
presidential trip to south america in
2012 we'll get to that i want to ask you
generally what about that story struck a
chord obviously not everything you write
for the paper has a book in it
the secret service story i mean when i
was drawn into this in 2012 at least it
was just the the two sides of this coin
you know
these heroic patriots who we all think
are the elite of the elite or we have
this hollywood impression button down
super fit
sunglasses
but as i did more and more reporting
about them i was finding out
there was a lot of seriously concerning
stuff you know that
they are willing to take a bullet for
the president but a lot of time they
were dodging a bullet a lot of time they
were covering up
uh not the secrets of the president but
their own mishaps their own
their own misconduct
something i was left thinking about was
the media environment where we're in
today
you know the carolinas of the world tell
us everything so we don't have to wonder
whether we're getting the whole story
we see both the visible part of the
iceberg and the submerged part but you
know in times past
when there were not carol lennox and
there were not as many places to get
news there were not as many enterprising
reporters i wonder if that's partly what
saved these guys in the old days is that
there was just no one to do the digging
and to report on this because as you say
all this stuff was there
and you're revealing it in a way that
for us we're hearing for the first time
but i think it's because nobody was
there to tell us before
right
i mean i think there were some excellent
reporters back in the day but there was
also a little bit of a gentleman's
agreement um you know we didn't cover
presidents in the sort of microscopic
proctological way we do now
um you know president kennedy a lot of
reporters knew that he was
often trotting off on business trips
really partially to meet women right
business
yeah that were not his wife and uh
and a lot of people knew what was
happening behind that curtain that what
he was doing in the swimming pool at the
white house when jackie was away
but we you know the secret service agent
saw something really really
disconcerting because while they weren't
judging him morally they were judging
him on a security reason they they felt
like he was taking his life in his own
hands the way he was interacting with
people he didn't know the women that
were unscreened that were you know on
the other side of the door at a hotel
room that they could the agents couldn't
see or screen or in some cases being
ushered into the white house by a friend
of the president i mean that's something
we'll come to the
the the kennedy story is one of many um
that i want to be sure we get into here
but let me stay
still kind of far back from this and ask
generally
as you say yourself in the prologue
you didn't go into this with a
conclusion about the secret service
intending to prove it right or yourself
right with your reporting but you did go
into it with a point of view and again
that was shaped in in large part by the
2012 experience
absolutely you know i i thought evan
when i dug into cartagena mess which
again you know i was asked to help
because i'm a digger and i i convinced
people to talk to me and tell me their
truths yeah i thought that was going to
be the biggest deal in the world the
most humiliating scandal in a hundred
years for the secret service but those
agents that i met over and over again so
many different ones that i met as a
result of that reporting and their
family members and their friends and
officers
they had a much more horrifying story to
tell that was more important than boys
gone wild in south america
and that was that they thought a
president was going to be killed on
their watch
right and so in some ways telling the
story is the best way for them to
cleanse themselves or cleanse their
guilt and maybe to cleanse the secret
service right getting it out there
they really didn't believe that their
leadership and they've been through
several directors they didn't believe
their leadership was listening to them
yeah they believed that you know the the
alpha male dna of this agency
is both amazingly capable of doing
heroic and unthinkable things such
sacrifice with their lives but that dna
also
doesn't admit weakness doesn't admit
that the agency's stretched too thin and
that it's its security system is really
swiss cheese right now yeah well
multiple things can be true at once they
can be both heroes and also be in need
of some kind of fix so you interviewed
180 people roughly for this book and it
sounds to me like many of them were
happy to talk to you as long as you
didn't identify them how do you feel
about the need to rely as you did for
this book on anonymous sources
well unfortunately in this instance it
was absolutely necessary
agents who are currently on duty and
officers
will lose their jobs if they speak to me
without permission and so
i have to admit and say with great
sadness that there are agents who lost
their jobs for talking to me so
anonymity is is crucial for them and
on top of that even former agents wanted
to be on background because of the
backlash that they would get from sort
of the alumni network that still wants
to burnish the image of a perfect
impenetrable secret service and he's not
willing to look out for the current team
that is you know fighting really against
the odds and needs help well as a
working reporter and especially for a
paper like the post where you are called
upon to rely on anonymous sources to
tell us all things that we absolutely
need to know you understand the tension
there because so many people distrust
the media
if they see anonymous sources then
they're given permission not to believe
what they're reading and you just have
to accept that as part of the bargain
yes although in this book and in my
reporting but especially in this book
it is the beneficiary of
copious documents for example in the
cartage episode i can tell you down to
the number of mojitos and beers that
certain agents had
because someone gave me all the internal
investigation documents
so
many of these agents submitted to me
their calendars their schedules their
contemporaneous texts and notes uh and
then they were backed up by again
internal documents
so you alluded to what the premise of
this book is that this storied
organization is stretched too thin that
it's drowning in new missions there are
great security risks there's distrust
between leadership and rank and file
i would also add as we see repeatedly
like so much of government they're
operating off of outdated technology
outmoded technology that doesn't keep up
with what they maybe need in the modern
world there's a frat boy culture
there's an aspect of this
in which the service has been drawn into
political matters and you want to hope
that the service is apolitical but maybe
that's too much to ask
and that people hate
working there that's kind of the part
that i thought was most remarkable you
say it finds itself in a state of
unprecedented
peril
shouldn't we all fear for the country
under those circumstances i mean the
secret service leave aside the myth of
the secret service as a practical matter
they're protecting the most important
people in this country
and if they're in this bad shape
shouldn't we all be concerned
you couldn't have said it better i mean
and indeed you voice exactly what my
sources told me agent after agent
officer after officer why'd they come to
me why'd they risk their careers why
they put that something on the line like
this
because all of the warning signs that
they know from history were were flaring
before kennedy was killed or flaring now
outdated technology
stretched too thin staff people back in
the day and i interviewed luckily some
of kennedy's agents
a few of them died in the course of me
working on this project um
they said they knew they were treading
water they knew they were in trouble
they knew they couldn't keep up and
that's what agents are telling us now
are we going to wait and see until
another disaster are we going to pay
attention and do something for them of
course that's 50 years ago i mean that's
the thing that's extraordinary is that
it's been allowed to continue despite
the fact that it is absolutely not a not
a new problem so as i'm reading this
book i'm thinking to myself
what does success look like for the
secret service what is the job
of these brave men and women
dick kaiser who is the special agent in
charge of protection a special agent for
nixon and ford says in the book
for is quoted saying in the book for me
it's just you've got to keep them safe
right i mean this reduces to the old
hashtag you had one job
the one job of these guys is you got to
keep the principles safe really nothing
else is more important than that
and it's so vital i mean the reason the
agency matters to me after learning so
much about it is right it's vital to the
democracy right if the president is
killed everyone who was alive at the
time remembers kennedy's death well if
if you think it was a gut punch to the
country
you can't imagine how bad it was for the
secret service because it was job one
but on top of on top this is one of the
things that's the problem with the
mission on top of job one there are 40
more people that the secret service
protects you know we're pretty the agent
agency is now protecting vice
president's stepchildren and president's
grandchildren and
on top of cabinet secretaries so you
know it's a huge mission plus they're
doing cyber security and hacking and
financial crimes they're they're
protecting super bowls they're
protecting olympics i mean you know
every single event
doesn't involve the president they're
they're still there
so
we as one dhs forgive me as one
senior cabinet member told me uh
this agency needs a refresh about
mission we have to we have to match up
its mission and the tools
with what we actually the money and the
tools we give them because right now
they cannot accomplish what they are
given yeah i mean you talk about the
as you take that off how broad the
mission is and how many things it's come
to incorporate
it's easy to forget that back when the
secret service came into existence it
really started as a counterfeit squad
right in at the time of of abraham
lincoln and it evolved only after
mckinley was assassinated into the into
the body that we know it is the entity
that it is today initially the purpose
of the secret service was not to protect
the principles it was much more mundane
so mundane you know basically it starts
after lincoln with the idea that you
know there's all this counterfeit money
and you know we've got to deal with
counter two-thirds i think of the paper
floating around after
in the last year of the civil war was
fake um so
you know there's a myth that the secret
service was authorized by president
lincoln um the day that he was shot uh
actually the idea was discussed with his
secretary of treasury and and then
launched not long after his
assassination but three more presidents
would be assassinated before the secret
service would take over the role
of guarding the principal uh guarding
the person who's the the leader of the
free world
and the reason was we're so american
right we don't want a praetorian guard
we don't want a royal palace the public
recoiled at that and presidents didn't
think that the taxpayers slash voting
public would cotton to this but you know
after mckinley was killed in brook and
um forgive me
in upstate new york in buffalo
finally people started to say you know
what this many presidents killed maybe
we should actually protect them um there
were so many things i learned from
your book about the service that's one
of them another is that the the service
has grown so much over the last six
decades from 300 agents and a 5 million
dollar budget to 7 000 agents
and a 2.2
billion annual budget extraordinary
growth um
i didn't know that the first and only
secret service officer to die while
protecting the president was during an
assassination attempt on harry truman
i'm not even sure i knew that there was
an assassination attempt carol
on harry truman leslie kaufman goes down
in history now as the one and only right
um and you just mentioned you know that
the the mission of the service has has
been expanded to do things like protect
the vice president the idea that that
was not part of this charge from the
very beginning is extraordinary i mean
could you imagine kamala harris in this
country at this moment
without a protective detail
no i can't i can't you know it took the
assassination of robert kennedy while he
was campaigning and looking like he was
heading to become president uh for
lyndon b johnson actually to just
announce overnight and then that's
actually a really chilling moment um
literally in the middle of the night
calls up the director of the secret
service and says i want details on every
single candidate right now right
um so
candidates got protection um
family members as you say i mean all
the the protection of the service has
been expanded to
so many people you know carol i didn't
know until i read this book that arthur
bremmer who shot george wallace actually
had wanted to kill richard nixon first
and he did and was thwarted i mean you
know
and that's actually a good story for the
secret service like you know he bremer
wrote in his wall in his um
in his journal
that he was trying to get nixon but it
was too tricky a tricky dick was too
tricky to get um he was struggling
because those secret service men he said
they just made it too hard for him to
get a close enough shot so good for them
you know kennedy
kennedy's assassination really made them
rebuild that agency from the ground up
rigorous training amazing security net
but it's been
slipping for the last couple decades um
i was not aware of something that you
referred to in this book called the
exceptional case study project this is
where
an analysis was done of
83 people who attacked or came close to
attacking prominent american public
figures between 1949 and 1996. they're
not all presidents
but that's an awful lot of instances of
attempts
many more than i knew or that i think
we'd probably remember
and the point made among others in this
study is that many of them were about
wanting fame this was not about
political ideologies right so
so something we learned about the secret
service in this book for sure is that
they've really got a much tougher job
than even we know because there are so
many more attempts
that someone could probably read about
right
so many i mean
even before obama president obama was
running for office barack obama um who
kind of set the record for the number of
threats there are thousands per month
that are registered in one way or
another maybe in a bar
somebody on a stool a little bit had too
many to drink says he's going to kill
the president to just an email or in a
or more frighteningly in a white
supremacist you know chatter group
somebody writes what they're planning to
do or uh
more often as was true in the
exceptional case study a person with
some mental struggles or maybe in a
crisis mental health state
decides that the way for them to solve
their problems is to kill a president
and everybody has to be taken seriously
that's the point is you don't know
whether somebody who just sends an email
is a serious threat or not you've got to
investigate
everything a number of times in this
book carol we hear more agents more
agents more agents we need more agents
and there are a number of anecdotes that
you recount
in which the service itself or others go
to congress they've got to they say we
need more agents the problem is we're
understaffed is that necessarily after
all your reporting have you concluded
the answer to a better secret service is
it volume
more agents would make for a better
service
in some ways yes but in other ways it's
too simplistic yeah as we as you've
pointed out the mission is enormous it's
gotten larger and larger we keep adding
to the pile of what the secret service
is responsible for
on the other hand right you can't not
protect kamala harris you can't not
protect the vice president and the
president's family right you have to
protect those people so those duties are
understandable but the mission creep is
enormous the other thing is technology
they are so
like
late 1900s in terms of what they have
for tools at their disposal some things
have been upgraded but you know even in
2017 when donald trump
was just a few months into his
presidency you know they had another
jumper incident where the person got
over five different fences and was on
the grounds for 15 minutes without being
interrupted jiggled the door on the east
wing to get in and wandered around again
no one catching him why because the
cameras the fence line the the alarms
the sensors so many parts of it were
failing so you know this can't be the
most protected 18 acre compound if all
those things were on the fritz
well so there's that problem i mean it's
not simply about the number of asians
but you also have this kind of more i
think of this kind of more work a day
problem which is that sometimes the
people who are being protected by the
secret service don't want them around
you know i i kept thinking to myself
while i was reading this book the number
of people who protect these
who refuse to be protected or don't want
to be protected i mean you use the case
of john kennedy which is the most um
extreme case of somebody who was trying
to to to uh to
cut and run or to leave his details so
he could go off and and have his
adventures but there are other people in
this book who seem to object i mean
president johnson right who just don't
really like the imposition of the even
though they know that the purpose of
having them around is to protect them
they would just assume not be protected
that's another point of tension
absolutely i'm so glad you brought it up
uh president johnson it makes me chuckle
a little bit because
he actually threatened and one time did
uh
shoot out the tire of a secret service
agent's car a follow-up car behind him
on his farm in texas and uh
he kept threatening to shoot it because
he said
you know you guys need to get back away
from me i'm hunting out here and you're
messing it up you're getting in the way
right exactly but there was another
thing about johnson and kennedy too in
terms of them wanting these agents away
separate from john f kennedy's you know
romantic days that's right yeah but
separate from that the other reason was
they didn't think the american public
wanted a lot of secret service guards
around their president they wanted to
feel like they were every man who who
waded into a crowd
normal joe say hello to their voters and
if you had a bunch of security around
you it gave the impression you needed to
be protected from your own public and
they didn't like that and they thought
taxpayers would be ticked off about it
so linda b johnson for example
constantly trying to cut the secret
service budget or at least his detail
because he thought voters didn't like it
but isn't there something fundamentally
ridiculous about that we'd rather have a
live president with too many people
around him than a dead president i mean
the fact is that the job of the secret
service is to protect the president and
i mean i i find it remarkable that the
taxpayers won't like this argument holds
any water i'm a little bit more
sympathetic
to the argument that well we want to
have private lives
and so whether it's john kennedy or
michelle obama
we want the secret service to leave us
to have our private lives and not to
impose in the way
that they might i mean it has the word
secret in it
but of course they do work for us so
that tension that idea that the culture
of the place may be steeped in deference
and discretion
but at the same time they may also
reveal the secrets of a president or of
the first family is that's going to be a
concern no matter what right and you
know there have been some presidents
that have had better relationships with
the secret service than others right so
you know
the bushes
had an incredible relationship with
their secret service details treated
them like family barbara bush always
running out with some hot coffee
bringing food right bringing the food
from the leftovers from the party right
i mean even to the point of telling a
detail leader for her husband that she
wanted him to wear you know her
husband's hat and mittens because it was
cold outside very motherly attention and
um
and and actually welcomed right but when
the clintons arrived
right they weren't they weren't so sure
about these agents looking out for them
and in fact within the first few weeks a
story leaked in the papers about hillary
clinton and throwing a lamp for her
husband in an argument right so
after that she's like okay it turns out
these agents like the bushes better than
us and that's right i don't want them in
our i don't want them right up on the
second floor of our house they're gonna
need to stay downstairs well in fact the
issue of the secret service's
relationship with the clintons and this
notion of deference and and all that
comes to a head during the star
investigation right when the question of
whether the secret service will tell
what they saw
on the lewinsky matter i mean you know
again it hadn't occurred to me that the
secret service would be put in the
position of having to play that kind of
role maybe i knew it at the time but i
forgot it but again your book in
in extraordinary detail
it's such a compelling story let's let's
get into some some presidencies if you
don't mind and let's talk about some of
the stuff that you
present to us um
the obviously the kennedy assassination
is is the one that a lot of people think
about we have this image of the secret
service
in dilly plaza and we think about
everything that happened on that day and
after
again under the heading of i think maybe
i knew this but i forgot it or maybe i
just didn't know it i didn't fully
appreciate that jackie kennedy blamed
the secret service
bill greer the driver of the limousine
who was an agent in the service you have
jackie in this book saying basically if
only he had done xyz differently maybe
that wouldn't happen that's
extraordinary to me
i mean
this widow um you know with the blood
still on her beautiful pink suit
uh
is holding on to her husband's brain
parts as they arrive at parkland i mean
literally clutching literally
a piece of his skull and brain holding
them and hands them to a doctor when she
gets into the emergency room right um
you know you can't put this president
back together again there were some
doctors who thought there was a chance
but not many
but she is a you know this amazing
figure of of
of like i'm gonna hold it together for
the country which she did for many many
days but in her private moments
she shares that that that tap on the
break
that bill greer the agent of the limo in
which she is riding with her husband
that tap on the break in the plaza upon
hearing the first shot come through the
right side of everybody's ears
is is likely the reason that hink
forgive me is likely the reason that
oswald was able to get a third and fatal
shot that went you know directly into
the jaw and ear of the president and did
result in a part of his brain
splattering on the backseat
right but of course the contrast to that
would be the assassination attempted
assassination of ronald reagan where
unlike jackie kennedy nancy reagan after
after the fact says
the agent saved him i mean they she she
believed that actually the system worked
exactly it was as it was supposed to so
rather than recriminations she felt like
had it not been for the agents that he
might have actually he might have
actually succumbed
absolutely and you know what that heroic
moment um so many levels of heroism and
smart split second trigger reflexes on
the part of the secret service that is
the result of the rebuilding after the
gut punch of kennedy's death you know
the director rowley puts everything up
that he has into getting the money
getting the agents getting the
technology all of that upgrade happens
and his choices and and the choices of
the directors that follow him are
completely vindicated by
the split second to six decision of
tim mccarthy
to throw his arms up in his chest up and
take incoming bullets from john
hinckling or the split second decision
of reagan's detail leader on that on
that on that square outside the hilton
as soon as he hears shots there's no
like tap the breaker let's look he puts
his hand on his shoulders and shoves the
pressure
into the car 70 year old man shoves him
into the car lands on top of him reagan
actually at one point thinks before he
knows that he's been shot he thinks that
his rib is broken because he's having
problems breathing and that's in part
because the guy smothered him
essentially in the car but he saved his
life he saved his life and the agent
behind him um ray shattuck who literally
folded up i don't know if he was going
to break the legs or not but he folded
up the legs of the agent behind him
jerry parr who was on top of the
president so that they could slam the
limo door shut and evacuate immediately
i mean it was like it was like a vietnam
uh evac unbelievable they went so fast
they went so fast that that agent who
was driving
um you know was was saying a mantra to
himself oh my god i hope i don't run
over timmy timmy was of course tim
mccarthy
who took the bullets and foul so that
chaos on that day extraordinary chaos
how much how much worse it could have
been but but
everybody made great decisions the fact
that hinckley was able to be 11 feet
from the president that was a failure
that's what they did wrong but what they
did right so overshadowed what they did
so i want to come back to reagan in a
second i thought the reagan and kennedy
contrast was interesting i'll go back to
nixon because to me the really
interesting takeaway from your writing
about nixon and the service was the
degree to which nixon politicized or
attempted to politicize the service by
my count the big grievous offenses or
attempted offenses were first of all he
wanted to use the secret service to
entrap ted kennedy
because he feared
kennedy as a political threat either in
the 72 election or he wanted to even
disable him potentially for 76.
nixon's relying on the service to take
on a number of expenses that were not
really legitimately
renovation expenses at nixon's private
properties um and then also nixon's
attempt to use secret service members to
remove protesters to basically disable
the ability of of americans to protest
peacefully
uh if not loudly uh against their
government i mean it heart it reminded
me carol of um of of what happened
during the trump years um and it and it
it reminded me of the same yeah i mean
there were so many eerie parallels
between nixon and trump just regarding
the secret service you know this idea of
we're gonna we're going to handle
anti-war protesters and anti-nixon
protesters by sticking the secret
service on them and using them kind of
as a tool president nixon's president
nixon's view of the secret service was
very much like
uh president trump's in that this is
another tool of my power not they're
protecting me but these are but more
like these are my goons
um and and donald trump deployed them
the same at lafayette square on june 1.
nobody can forget the president's wish
president trump's wish to look as the
law and order president the tough guy
look tough right yeah look tough don't
look weak and nixon wanted to do the
same when he was running for reelection
he wanted to have these images of these
sort of vicious savage protesters
fighting with the secret service so that
those could be the images in the news
pages and and that could show
the voters who was going to keep them
safe president nixon yeah so come back
to reagan again something i may be new
but your book reminded me is that the
president reagan when he was shot
lost nearly half the blood in his body
i remember being in middle school when
president reagan was shot
and hearing about it and knowing enough
to know that it was a big deal
but at the same time never thinking that
he almost died
i mean lost nearly half the blood in his
body
it is a stunning stunning thing and and
hats off to the george washington
university doctors and the surgeon that
put him back together again i mean they
dealt with a lot of challenges but part
of the reason evan that you weren't
might maybe weren't aware of it at the
time is because the secret service in
the white house were seriously keeping
that under wraps how close he came to
death was very much only something we
learned later right yes so hidden and
you know the surgeons dug out a
devastator bullet out of the side of his
lung which was hidden um behind a rib so
it was really hard for them to find yeah
um you mentioned how things changed over
these different instances you know that
ever with every moment
i mean i'd use the example jonathan
wackrow who's quoted a couple times in
the book was a presidential detail agent
who says every time the service is
tested it gets better right so the
assumption is they go through jfk
well after jfk now they're going to
check the security of buildings along
the motorcade route to prevent sniper
fire and they're going to be no more
open top convertibles after the wallace
assassination attempt we're going to
change policies regarding rope lines
after the reagan assassination attempt
now we're going to add
magnometers and we're going to have
covered arrivals all of this seems smart
and normal like to a civilian i'm
thinking of course
but then of course i'm thinking back to
the capital insurrection where after the
capital insurrection just a couple of
months ago
nancy pelosi and the security detail in
the in the house the capitol police were
going to add metal detectors
right
and it's such a point of controversy
right
as if the answer to every question is
subject verb liberty as opposed to these
are the leaders of our country and we
have to protect them so as much as we
see the security protocols evolve over
time
it's not without controversy right
and why i mean you know this better than
anyone evan
the problem here is security mixed with
politics right right nancy pelosi is has
never really wanted and has really
pretty much resisted offense around the
around the capitol why it looks terrible
um the
president trump didn't like the new
fence design that they were envisioning
to try to prevent these jumper incidents
that were so humiliating he said it
looked like a prison um
people kennedy didn't want detail agents
on the back of his car when they were
riding in motorcades well clint hill
will tell you they begged begged to be
on the back of that car and if and in
fact had they had they been that it
might have actually prevented oswald
from having a good shot at the president
right
100 i think that they would have had a
fighting chance to prevent his death and
as clint hill has said to me and others
he would have taken that bullet he would
have gotten in between it and the
president now we don't want that
but that is what they signed up for and
yeah all of these security issues when
you mix them with politics and people's
politic political impression
you don't get a pure security answer
yeah well it's always a tension between
freedom
and security right i mean this is always
going to be the tension whether it's
with the secret service or the capital
fencing right you want to protect
everybody but you also want you want to
have the ability to be free so i i'm
just moved you know i hit this point in
the book where i was like where did
everything go wrong
the problems you identify had been a
plague on the secret service for years
and again we may not have known
about them as much out here in the world
but there was a u.s news story that you
referred to in 2002 that details this
long history
of bad behavior of all kinds by agents
and yet i can't help but note that your
chapter on the obama years is titled the
wheels come off as if somehow the wheels
had been on
previously
but it was really in the obama years
that we really see the problems up close
right and and they seem if anything to
get worse
they absolutely got worse so there are
two things going on at the same time
one is
that after clinton's presidency there is
an effort especially by president
clinton to keep agents away from him
right and as they get further and
further away from him
their ability to secure him reduces and
there's it's the it's the advent of the
tv president right you don't want the
agents in the shot keep them a little
bit further away we want a visage of a
strong independent president nobody
protecting him nobody needs to be there
so that starts a downward cycle in terms
of the rigor of their security yeah
there's also the
the
the misconduct is allowed and the
because of an arrogance and secrecy and
lack of transparency in the culture of
the secret service if they can keep
classified programs that are important
to protect the president's secret they
seem to believe they can also keep their
weaknesses right and and some of their
humiliating episodes a secret
and they both of those things come to a
horrible head during president obama's
uh two administrations just episode
after episode um of both kinds security
gaps and and unbelievable bad boy so i i
was chronicling as i'm reading i'm
writing down everything bad that happens
during the obama years and at a certain
point i was like i just have to stop
because the volume of it was too much
you have the extraordinary racist
culture of the service come out these
horrible emails and these horrible
racist jokes that are made
remember that of course that president
obama is a special case in that he is
the first
black president ultimately
he he receives secret service protection
the earliest any candidate has received
security in the history of the
protective detail right that's right um
right um you have the south american
trip the cartagena trip that was the
basis for your post story which of
course because you own that subject
carol you go into an excruciating detail
in the book the best kind of
excruciating
and so you know every single thing twist
and turn that happen you have the fence
jumper who gets into the white house in
2014. i think his name is ortega is that
right that's right this is a comedy of
errors except that it's not even a
little bit funny how like you referred
to earlier with the trump instance how
did this guy
manage to escape being seen you have the
agents who drive drunk into the security
barrier and then for good measure you
have the leaking of jason chaffetz's
failed secret service application this
is all within
a period of a few years
and it's extraordinary to me that that
nothing really seems to improve during
that period
the
the
the shocker
is everybody in the
everybody in the obama white house
threw up their hands
after the jumper and after another
incident that followed like minutes
after almost which was an elevator guard
who was allowed to get close to the
president president obama right
with a weapon and he actually actually
had a weird history didn't he he had a
history that would have suggested you
don't want this person by
conventional standards near the
president
anybody who's not um absolutely clean
should not have a weapon and be near the
president this person had been charged
although not convicted but charged with
some crimes that in involved in use of
uh a gun
should have been a red flag a red flag
everybody should have been screened
bottom line but after these two things
happened the obama white house is like
okay we're done and they
ask and pressure for the director's
resignation thinking that a new leader
is going to make things all the better
but when they bring back
you know father joe joe clancy who used
to be the head of president
obama's detail and who he feels really
comfortable with somebody of great
rectitude you know a great coach when
they bring him back and they they're all
like taking a big sigh of relief like
things are going to get better but no
right things things do not get better
and
nothing changes the status quo and these
two people one of them the highest
ranking member
of the president's detail in charge of
all of security at the white house
leaves a retirement party drunk as a
skunk and comes back onto the white
house compound
with another inebriated person they
drive their government car onto the
white house complex so they can collect
another car over a suspicious package
investigation you know this is not the
behavior of people who are on their game
at all times or or a functional entity
like this i mean that's the thing you
don't you don't hear these stories and
think well this place seems to be
working out okay i mean i didn't even
mention
the the bullets that pierce the the res
residents of the white house right and
mrs obama goes bananas over this
right yes if you're the
if you're the first lady and you find
out from the white house usher five days
after the fact that the house that your
children were in was shot at while you
were away
it's not a good way to learn the
information if you're a mom much less
the first lady
it's extraordinary so we get into the
trump years
and
what are the big takeaways from the
relationship between trump and the and
the secret first of all
the cost man there were a lot of costs
associated with the trump administration
that we either found out at the time in
many cases thanks to the reporting of
your colleagues at the post or we're
finding out now we're far in excess of
what we knew and far in excess of what
by normal standards they should have
been
a whole lot of people were protected
in the trump years by the service right
significantly more than have been
protected in the normal administration
yes
in fact it was breaking the bank i mean
there were 42 people including including
the president um at one point you know
who the head then of the department of
homeland security john kelly who ended
up being the chief of staff you know
tries to get some people to give up
their details because they're not under
any kind of security threat he asked
steve mnuchin you know we don't have
enough money to protect the president
can we have your detail steve mnuchin
goes bananas wants to keep his detail
others give them up kellyanne conway
gave up her detail because she cared she
wasn't thrilled about it but she gave it
up because right it was the right thing
to do at a certain point you got to make
choices um you mentioned the president
wanting aesthetic changes you know the
fence and all that he wanted to remove
those
um uh
one of those movable uh posts that sort
of up and down yeah the underground
security gates that are that rise and
fall rise and fall because he didn't
like the fact that when you ran over
them they made kind of an unpleasant
noise or it was a little jarring
i mean i mean to me the the thing that i
i suppose i
i shouldn't be surprised about because
the president was so
concerned about the look of the people
around him for four years
was his concern that there were
overweight people on the security detail
i want these fat guys off my detail is
an actual quote
right from from president trump and he
said it because he was concerned that
they wouldn't be in the shape
to protect him so there was a physical
aspect to it but you can't help but
think that the president who was like
the casting director for his
administration in chief
is thinking
you know people who don't look the image
that i want them to look back to what
you said at the beginning of this
conversation about the hollywood image
of the service
they were they were banished from his
detail
you know you you've drawn such a
beautiful through line for something
that worries me about the service and
part of the reason i wrote the book yeah
president trump
takes over at a time when the service is
recovering and trying to rebuild trying
to rebuild right they've gone through a
horrific eight years
episode after episode after episode
but what does donald trump care about
using them as a tool
optics over reality he doesn't care
about governing he hasn't paid any
attention to their financial straights
the short change nature
instead his travel bleeds them dry 30
million dollars is necessary in spring
of 2017 he's only been president for a
few weeks
they make it the secret service makes an
emergency request because they can't
they know they won't be able to keep up
with even the basic bare minimum because
president's going to mar-a-lago every
other weekend to golf and travel
that is very unusual it's not unusual
for presidents to travel it's unusual
for them to have leisure travel that
puts money in the pocket of their own
company taxpayer money and there was
quite a bit of concern about the obama
expenses associated with security but in
the very first few months of the trump
years it seemed like trump was going to
far exceed what the the worst and as you
point out some of that money had to
actually go to trump owned businesses
right so it's our money to protect the
president higher than we would normally
expect to have to pay and ultimately
ends up in the pockets of
of trump associates
yes
and so
back to your great through line
donald trump arrives the service needs
help it gets less and less help it's
more shortchanged more bled dry and the
person in charge is focusing on the
optics about whether or not they're fat
or not right um although many agents
have told me they think that the
president misunderstood who he was
talking about that those were other
people who had desk jobs but whatever um
the optics are more important and the
problem is then the service gets to the
service leadership gets to take you know
a pass and not look harder at their
bigger problems deeper within you know i
think about the obama and the trump
years related separate but related
you know the fact that you had the first
black president and the nature of the
threats
to the first black president and his
family on the one hand on the other hand
the challenge of the kinds of rallies
and the kinds of rally goers in the
trump years i mean to me those present
real serious challenges even for a
secret service at its best let alone a
secret service that is short staffed and
under under budget
so true
director clancy who was still director
while um
forgive me while donald trump was
running against hillary clinton gave an
interview in which he said that it was
the most chaotic campaign he'd ever seen
in his life um and he he was more
careful in his language than others but
agents told me they had dubbed president
trump the chaos candidate because the he
was inciting violence at his own rallies
when protesters who were anti-trump
arrived he would encourage his
rally-goers to physically attack them
i'm saying that he would pay their legal
bills hey they're legal bills we
remember that right if you get in
trouble i'll pay your bills
so
i mean there's a horrible scene where a
woman from the university in louisville
is in a kentucky convention center where
the president is speaking she has come
basically to protest his anti-muslim
sort of rhetoric and
she is pushed around like a rag doll she
is black she is
wearing a backpack she has a phone and
she is filming what's happening to her
and
watching it from up above is horrifying
because as men spit on her call her
names
racial epithets and and almost push her
to the ground um
but
they did so at donald trump's urging
yeah i mean another way i want to ask
you this question is the current
political environment has to from the
services perspective present more of a
threat the toxicity of it
the pervasiveness of conspiracy theories
that you know
you would have once dismissed as
ridiculous and not even worth
paying attention to i mean the kid who
shot up the white house during
the obama administration you write was
inspired by
the an alex jones movie right i mean
what what must it be like today for the
service having to deal with everything
else now suddenly having to deal with
these conspiracy theory fueled
attacks or conspiracy theory inspired
rallies
that themselves then create more
problems from a protective standpoint
well
such a such a wise set of worries
because look at what happened january
6th right nobody imagined it yeah nobody
imagined it but nobody really could have
handled it other than you know several
phalanxes of national guard you know we
can't pretend that a a slightly larger
capital police force could have handled
that um just a stunning display of
of of the state in which our country is
really nearly nearly civil war
proportions right and as you point out
uh there were a number of secret service
agents who post insurrection we learned
sympathy sympathized or at least
empathize with the one six rioters which
gets back to this question of whether
the secret service can never be properly
apolitical right you're going to have
individuals who are going to have
political points of view the president
is going to
choose or not choose to unlock that part
of it but they themselves may have
political points of view and
and and that complicates matters further
you know a law enforcement agency in
america is almost always going to trend
conservative yeah but i was
just gobsmacked to have
sources and agents send me the
screenshots of their colleagues who are
on the presidential detail you know
cheering for the
patriots who had stormed the capital to
stop the stolen election
when if you have the most elite agency
in protection in the world allegedly um
and some members are are stoking the
belief that biden is not a legitimate
president you know how safe is the
democracy how safe is president biden
right and of course you don't write
about biden very much in this book it's
you know kind of the
there's some mention of of the new
president do you have any sense of what
it's been like sort of if there's a
paperback version of this book which
there will be theoretically the new
material will be about the first
period of the by administration and
whether he was able to reset everything
or whether it was more of the same what
is your what's your sense
i have heard that a lot of senior former
agents that were close to
uh former vice president biden are
trying to spread the word partially
through my book
pointing to it but but but also their
own experience is to say it's time
it's time to fix it let's not wait for a
disaster are we not are we going to pay
attention now
or are we just going to wait until
something horrible happens right which
of course if we can go back to the
beginning of our conversation it took
three assassinations before the secret
service really stepped up and stepped in
we hope that it's not going to take
another one before these problems get
fixed i really hope so carol i love this
book uh and it is so great to talk to
you and you know i feel like i really
have learned an enormous amount not only
reading the book but spending this time
with you thank you so much for making
time for me
i really love talking about it with you
evan thank you
thank you carol and evan that was really
enlightening i'm imagining that a lot of
you would like to have a copy of this
book zero fail the rise and fall of the
secret service we do have signed book
plated copies available at our lbj store
which you can access at lbjstore.com
here's a look at some books being
published this week